yo
yo all right right right
all right
right
more than one million dollars worth of
jewelry stolen all while a renowned
brooklyn bishop presented his sunday
sermon they
took all of my wife's jury and took all
of my jury
and
and then they left
however
these
young men
didn't know that cameras were on the
leaders of tomorrow international
ministries live streams its services and
last sunday was no different as bishop
lamore miller whitehead addressed his
congregation a group of masked gunmen
interrupted
[Music]
nobody
whitehead detailed the incident on
instagram live captioning the video yes
they robbed me in my church and when i
seen the armed men come in
you know it was specifically for me
um it was specifically for me and um and
of course my wife
and when i see them come into the
sanctuary
with their guns
i told everybody get out everybody just
get out whitehead says three people
armed and wearing all black interrupted
the sunday sermon he says one of the
suspects pointed a gun at his
eight-month-old daughter's face at the
same time all of his wife's jewelry was
taken after that his jewelry was also
stolen
[Music]
whitehead said he chased the suspects
out of the church where they hopped into
a white mercedes-benz vehicle at the
time about 25 congregants were present
whitehead now says churchgoers are
traumatized right everybody get out i
didn't know if they wanted to shoot
the church up or um if they
were just coming for a robbery the
bishop known for wearing designer
outfits and flashy jewelry says he and
his family were specifically targeted
you know sometimes
you know when you are a known bishop
um
[Music]
you know it's a gift and a curse when
you have some what of a celebrity status
um
it is a gift for the curse you know you
become the
uh the talk of the town the new york
police department received a report on
the incident and says the investigation
is still ongoing for the latest
developments in this story and all
things true crime stay with law and
crime network for long crime network i'm
sierra gillespie